what do I think about consignment as a
business model I'm going to answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn so Risa got asked a question from
one of my loyal YouTube viewers love you
guys Pete who wrote in asking about
consignment and whether I thought it was
a good model as an artist to have have
his work shown in stores but only on a
consignment basis and so in my view once
you have a quality product the thing
that you need to get its distribution
right you need people out there buying
it you need the awareness if the
attention need to get some dollars and
some sales coming in and the ideal way
is as an artist is to have it pre bond
right I guess any entrepreneur if you're
selling a product the ideal way and then
living in a perfect world it's free bot
right where before you go in and invest
your time with energy to create
something you've already made orders
from it and that's using Kickstarter and
that's using your own hustle and that's
signing up potential partners or
potential customers for you before you
actually create anything that's the
ideal way because you have zero risk
right you know you're going to make some
money off of it and ideally then you
could leverage that into other things
other planes other products and you're
being paid up front that's the ideal way
but if you can't make that happen then
you have to look for alternative ways to
get distribution for what you're
creating and consignment is one of those
ways and for those of you don't know
consignment that's basically getting a
store to take on your product but not
guaranteeing anything right they're not
guaranteeing a sale if it sells they get
a commission if it doesn't sell then it
just stays up there and so the downside
is you have products sitting on
somebody's shelf and it's not getting
you know that's not a product that she
could be sold somewhere else and so I
would do the consignment deal if I had
no other options because it gives you
some distribution I'm sitting here
outside the YouTube headquarters I just
came out of a meeting you can see my
badge Evan Carmichael YouTube and
YouTube and I have a kind of consignment
relationship right I upload videos
that's my art that's one of the things
that I do and I don't get paid by
YouTube to do it i put it up on their
channel and they don't pay me directly
but they go and they sell advertising
right they sell sponsorships and so i
get paid some money from youtube ads
then they're out selling for me right so
we have a consignment relationship and
on top of that I get awareness I get
distribution so people hear about me
they learn about me they asked me if I
can do custom videos for them they asked
me if I can partner up with them on
different projects that's ideally what
you want for your business p if you're
an artist or any entrepreneur you want
somebody who's going to ideally promote
you to help give you money but also
promote you to spread your awareness
spread your message and that could lead
to other types of partnerships and deals
so if i was doing consignment I would
look for one a store that I thought
might have the access to my target
audience who would be buying your art
and do they have that time of clientele
and if they do then you can anticipate
potential sales but also just people
knowing about you hearing about you
looking at your stuff attention is value
right you can capitalize on attention
somebody asked me what is my business
how do i make money is I gather a ton of
attention in the entrepreneurial space
and then I capitalize on it and so it's
just kind of adjust in your philosophy
work if you're out there creating
awareness before knowing about you that
adds value that will come back your
business in ways that you can't even
think about at the moment the extra
little gravy and maybe curveball that I
would throw to you is I would then
whatever store I work with try to make
that store success anything that I'm a
part of any any business any person I'm
helping I want that person to do well if
you are around me I want you to do well
I want to be a part of your success I
don't want you to be mediocre and so if
i had my art that was what i was doing
in a store that I would work with that
store to build their own awareness I
would try to have events at that store I
would follow that store in social media
I would promote them on social media I
would try to get close to their founder
whoever the manager is and do things
with them that would that would help
them in a full circle way it helps you
but it's just being a part of helping
people who are a part of your life and
your business I think is important so
yes is the date of the analytics the
will this you know company this store
helped me sell more of my product but
then I take it to the next step
and tap into their heart and have
anybody who is associated with you in
any way start to rise up start to do
better start to have more results just
by being around you when you create that
aura then you're going to start
attracting the right people into your
life the right customers into your life
the right partners and media and
investors and suppliers into your life
so go out and create that or I went on a
little curveball out there that wasn't
expecting but that's how we roll God
have a great meeting with YouTube and I
was excited to make this video so thank
you guys so much for watching I would
love to know your thoughts on
consignment how have you use it have you
had success with it pros and cons from
your own personal experience or if
you're thinking about it let me know
leave a comment below thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon my arm is getting
tired from holding who